um so a lot of writers who have their
work adapted to film or television are
not really involved they kind of hand it
over and sometimes that can create a
distant or even adversarial relationship
with the adaptation you are not like
that you've been a producer on Game of
Thrones and you've also written script
for some of the most iconic episodes and
I want to shout out a few of them
including you wrote the pointy end which
has this amazing scene where serial
Ferrell protects Arya she escapes her
life is never the same again I hope this
is like a spoiler heavy zone so you can
feel free to ex is behind you if you
need to leave
so you wrote that episode that I loved
Blackwater a incredibly epic a battle
that I think rivals ministereth for
great on-screen battles where Tyrion
proves himself to be a capable military
strategist we get lots of sweet dragon
fire exploding the line in the Rose
where we bid for some of us a very
gleeful farewell to Joffrey and we
realize that we can see a miner die on
TV and we're somehow like happy about it
and so at the same time so you're
heavily involved in the show I'm still
speaking in the present tense but you
know I'm working through my own things
and
but you're still writing this series and
you really reserve the right to do what
you want there autonomously not based on
people's responses to the TV series this
is a long way of asking how do you see
the relationship between TV Westeros and
fiction Westeros and how how are you
operating in both of these worlds well
how many children did Scarlett O'Hara
have I'm the wrong one as that she had
three and Margaret Mitchell's novel she
had one in the movie hmm
so how many children did she have I mean
which is right the actual answer to that
it's a trick question of course as
Scarlett O'Hara had no children because
she's a fictional character and never
existed there's two different mediums in
two different ways of telling the same
story or at least a similar story and
that's true whenever you adapt any work
to from television or from books to
television or movies or even a radio
play for that matter you have to make
choices as to what you leave in what you
take out there are issues that a
television producer or a screenwriter
has that a novelist does not have you
know you have to worry about the budget
you have to worry about the running time
you have actors who have contracts you
know that have to be serviced I can I
could have a character like Theon
Greyjoy or Varys disappear for entire
books and you know not be mentioned at
all and perhaps be presumed dead or at
least you there often you don't know
your what they're doing you can't do
that with a TV show I mean the actors
are under contract you're not gonna pay
it actor for an entire season and not
have them appear on the screen
television film have things that they're
disposal that the novelist does not have
they can have a score like did wonderful
music we were hearing by brahmand wadi
or emmy winning composer
that you know reinforces we have been
marvelous special effects and all that
but the mahvelous also has tools that
the screen writer and the director don't
have he can use a unreliable narrator he
has the wonderful strength which I used
very heavily in a Song of Ice and Fire a
point of view the camera is completely
objective it has no point of view the
camera is showing you what happened when
I write a scene from the viewpoint of
Sansa filtering everything's responses
perceptions Sansa is only seeing what
she's looking at if there's something
behind her she doesn't see it but it's
more difficult to write when you're
doing it with a camera so all of these
things all of these things necessay
necessitate making changes making a
different approach so that's what the
process of adaptation is about and then
it's up to the readers and the viewers
to decide which they like better they're
both works of art Margaret Mitchell's
novel it's there it can be read you can
go see the 1939 movie still love if you
take into take into account inflation
all that's still the highest-grossing
movie of all time and you can determine
what you like better and argue about how
many children's you should have had but
there it is it's it's a two different
works of art related but not identical
mm-hmm almost like alternate universe
versions of each other so initially when
people started showing interest in the
series for television you felt that the
scale of it might be beyond what could
be represented on film especially
because of partially what you just
mentioned the scope of your mini
characters the world the complexity of
the plot what do you think was the
x-factor
is there something that changed or
something that made it work despite
those challenges of the medium well I
you know I I think HBO was part of the
age factor HBO was willing to make us
let us make an adult fantasy you know
fantasy books had been dominating the
best
lists for decades but whenever fantasy
was done on for TV for Game of Thrones
they put it on at 8 o'clock 7:00 central
and it was in the family hour because
that people running television thought
fantasy dragons and swords and stuff
that was something silly it was just for
children HBO had enough faith to
redefine at least in terms of television
to redefine the fantasy genre and that
doesn't surprise me because you look at
what they did previously Deadwood
only take on westerns Sopranos
completely different take on the
gangster story as a trio was in the
business of redefining genres and
inverting tropes and turning them on
their head so they did it in fantasy and
also David Benioff and Dan Weiss the
showrunners did an amazing job and they
assembled a great team a great team you
know Game of Thrones has won at this
point more Emmys than any of the show in
the history of television primetime show
anyway and what's interesting about is
many many many of those Emmys are what
they call in Hollywood below the line
there for things like music costuming
casting stunt work all of these things
special effects all of these things are
necessary to do a good thing and
novelist doesn't have to worry about
that I can I can just write what the
costumes are and and you know I don't
have to worry about that but a
showrunner has to put together a team of
people who can do it and who can do it
in the case of Game of Thrones with
extraordinary passion and skill to
produce something that is really really
memorable and outstanding and David
Benioff and Dan Weiss did that they put
together one of the greatest production
teams and cast and crews in the in the
entire history of television I think I
think the costume I mean there's so many
of those things you just mentioned that
I could shout out but the costuming in
particular right we see characters cost
I'm thinking of Daenerys obviously right
and the kind of progression of costuming
over the course of their personal
development as a character yeah
definitely
everything everything plays a role and
all it takes is one person to screw up
and and you know you're watching the
first episode of some new fantasy show
and it seems to be promising and the
dialogue is good and and maybe the
special effects are good and then you
spot a zipper and suddenly your
suspension of disbelief is out the
window and you say what the hell you
know and they've lost you know you have
to get yet in everything right it's it's
being a showrunner of a major television
show is really a difficult achievement